the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok ah so the take-home exam it should be
released by the end of this lecture and
I hope we will be fine problems I spend
the weekend trying to make up the
problem in addition writing five letters
and write a report
ah but see submitting probably is always
interfere but also interesting so I was
talking to Jonas and hopefully he'll
write a paper based on these problems
okay ah now coming back to what we're
talking in the last lecture we were
discussing really the now chapter eight
the title is the coupled principle that
energy conversion and my view here is
when we think about the energy
conversion
it's microscopically it's a one form of
the energy carrier transform the energy
into the other form and and that
transfer that the coupling process is
the water when we use both my equation
is reflected in the scattering term and
in this scattering term we have a
scattering rate which approximately in
the perturbation limit we can use the
Fermi golden rule to calculate that
scattering rate so we took a electron
photon company as an example we say okay
if I have the photon lattice vibrate and
change the separation between
the atoms and that's the faculty with
changing the pure-d city or that the
electron experience and that's the
deformation potential with death
defamation potential we actually went
through the derivation redone day from a
golden rule and say what's that a
scatter matrix to look like from that
that we say that actually gives the
latter a Fermi Golden Rule and in the
manipulation of scatter matrix naturally
give you the energy and the momentum
conservation and then we move down to
say okay if I plug in the scattering
rate which is a typical coupling to
different particles into the scattering
term which has to include all the
possible collisions or the possible
scattering and of course we know this
scattering term is very complicated but
at the end of last lecture I said this
is a very often presenting in boxing see
science physics or electrical
electronics if you split this F into a
first row of zeros order which are even
term and the R term and using that
current because any function can always
have an even an author write summation
any function is split into even out term
summation and they plug in back into the
scattering integral you find out is that
this split the led to actually in the
case of example with discussion electron
folder led to two terms in this scatter
and one of the term is approximately you
can use the relaxation approximation and
turns out the physics are physically
this term is the elastic scattering it's
a process where there's no see for
example when you like Tron fold on
scatter there's no energy change just a
direction change okay or the the outer
term
Unitas scattering and turns out the in
ask scattering term you cannot rigger
speaking you cannot use the relaxation
time approximation so just don't be
surprised if you write a paper you use
the board's my equation and at the end
say people had relaxation time say I
thought that's not valid in fact we have
that experience
that's a say a reviewer say divorce my
equation is not valid for in that in
Alaska scattering process so this is the
where it came from
okay and are the so the point that I'm
going to make next is there are
different process you can write the
similar expression study words along the
same approach Fermi Golden Rule you can
calculate the scattering matrix that's
the interaction that's the see for
example if we have semiconductor and
night comes in and that can interact
exciting electron if the electron from
valence band to the conduction band and
we have h nu here and that process you
can describe a user firming Golden Rule
that's the absorption scale of process
so you can calculate the absorption
fundamentally you can calculate the
absorption coefficient of the material
using this approach and now once I have
the electron lifted create a hole and
the electron hole in the valence band
and you'll actually in the conduction
band and if you look at a can get it
right yeah I want the solar cell I want
making solar cell and the energy of the
electron hole are here and of course you
want take this energy out to the
electrode then it's a competition
reprocess because if I think about here
right I have electron and have a hole I
turns out there are different
possibilities and of course in the solar
seal what happens to you create a
gradient of this charge carrier and they
would diffuse towards the electrode but
that takes time right Annie
say it takes time to for this diffusion
to happen and in the process the access
energy of the electron because the
electron photon scattering that's the
one that we treated you can go to for
example plugging typical numbers and the
electron photon scattering is very fast
so it's hard to actually get that energy
out directly and they were relaxed to
the bottom and this is a if you can
extract with this electron energy before
they relax to the bottom there's some
idea people tried in the past a lot of
people reading this is a hobby electron
right the electrons still hot and if you
can extract them those are hot electron
skills people reading in the 70s nobody
has really realized conception
responsible nobody has really realized
and the benefit is over sure so
similarly the holes were relaxed right
and once they got here then you have the
possibility so the electron and hole
will recombine and give out the energy
and you can have two recombination
process of why is in meter H nu this
will read it you so really the
recombination right and the other
possibility is actually give us a lot of
photons right again this is a chi omega
just to see the still H nu about the
photon vibrational energy is much
smaller right so the band gap energy is
user larger so this typically would
involve multipolar right motor photon
processes so this is a long reading here
okay
so you have a radial arterial radio -
recombination and of course if you say
you want to make a laser for example you
want the redo recombination you don't
want to lose this you want to extract
the energy at the photons it turns out
that even you might want to make a solar
cell as we will talk today you want this
really the recombination or the non
radiative recombination and but this
even this is not all representative of
all the possibilities one other
possibility is that now I have electron
here I have hole here and the interact
of course they will release their energy
and in this process they don't release
twofold how they don't release the folo
they give their energy to less labour
electron and so what they happen is this
energy is kick the electron here to a
higher energy State okay and again you
know you don't like this one because
once the energy this electron gets to a
higher energy state you are relaxed
quickly back so that access energy is
lost again to the folder because of this
process right and unless you can like I
said extract the hot electron out and
this is the ogia process odor
recombination okay so there are all
those processes in theory you can go to
describe using the quantum mechanical
scatter matrix method and write it down
and and the C calculate the scattering
rate so if I write the boards my
equation say so this scattering term is
a lot more complex right so before we
to use they say relaxation time
approximation and now you can see I have
a really example I can have scattered
really electron photon right this could
be electron fooling scatter I could also
have say generation right if I have
photon comes in that will generate
electron-hole pairs depends on will
carry your character I see
considering and then I have
recombination really do Rica or learn
relative all those are possible and this
is on the right hand side of the board's
by equation right on the left hand side
is the transport is the diffusion and
the moving under electric field right so
at the end I have a coupling of the
energy conversion you can think that to
the right hand side right hand side
boards by equation and the the transport
is on the left hand side of the equation
and there is the competition if we want
to extract the useful energy out to the
electron so our just in terms of
terminology a little sidetrack one
terminology if you do solar cells you do
lasers one term larger that's used often
is called quantum efficiency so what
does quantum efficiency mean so just as
definition and this are all engineering
language at the end because to do this
calculation you can see already it's
very much very involved right so see the
quantum efficiency is depends on what
I'm making whether I'm making a laser or
solar cell right so if I'm making for
example
laser what I want if I make a laser for
example I want photons right and I
inject a current which means I inject
the electron hole pairs right and one
pair of electron hole I inject into
device in theory perfectly what do you
want you want get a one year photon all
right so this is the quantum efficiency
is the number of photon you get versus
the number of electron hole you inject
right and this is a laser or say LED now
if you use solar cell it's a reverse
right you have one photon comes in you
want to extract a one pair of electron
holes and so one electron hole pair and
one photon so this is a solar cell right
and this is quantum efficiency then you
read the literature sometimes people say
what's the external quantum efficiency
was an internal quantum efficiency right
so you have external you have internal
quantum efficiency and what you're
talking about is a safe example are you
will make a device make a solar sea oh
you have the electrode right what can
actually be go into the electrode that's
externally but how many electron hole
pairs steady state that you have inside
right the device that's an internal so
you have the difference between internal
and external quantum efficiency people
use those to characterize how
effective because say normally we think
one pair of the electron hole will
generate one pair of photon or burst or
so however recently if you read
literature there's some people say how
quantum efficiency larger than one what
does that mean right so this is the way
you think about it you want to make a
let's suppose I have band gap here right
and I have very high energy photon comes
in okay and very high energy photon so
this is an electron this is a hole and
generates a high energy electron and a
hole in the band and if you lucky right
these are all the different reprocess
this electron will relax down
it does not interact with the folder you
will actually give the access a energy
to lift another electron out of the
valence band to the conduction band
right of course that means this energy
electron energy has to be larger than
the band gap
otherwise that's impossible right and
that's multi carrier multiple so
wonderful in this case effectively one
photon comes in it generally more than
one electron hole pairs and you know of
course you would love to have that in
when you try to make a solar cell
because that's the people to call this a
multi exit on generation okay
and here you can say you have to compete
against the different rate right
otherwise they if they fall out suck the
energy away and you can have that multi
exit on whether that happens there are a
lot of will fight in the scientific
community is the same people claim they
have seen very high multi exit on
generations there were other
people I just ran professor mu Qi Gong
Bao nd and it was involved in this
debate on whether the multi exit on
generation it's indeed happening or not
okay so uh that's a see just a summer
side track in terms of definitions but
say coming back to divorce my equation
right now say we said that on the right
hand side you can have multiple terms on
the left hand side is a standard say
diffusion drift OSI in the case of no
size effect and when they're size the
fact I had to do past integral as we
solve this sportsman equation right so
what I'm going to introduce at different
forms and if I talk about electron right
so for example when you have a metal and
you have laser comes in very fast laser
and what happens to the laser energy is
in the case of a photon comes into a
metal is used to lift the energy of the
electron it's the electron absorption
right so that's the first step of the
interaction and once the energy of the
electron lifted to very high temperature
you can see this is a really giving
electron itself is allowing equilibrium
process right because the laser
frequencies are fixed and if I think
about our typical electronica right
energy level this is the Fermi level
this is a band and electron can be
lifted to a very high energy and by say
it's a not even in equilibrium with the
shell however electron-electron
interaction itself is very fast because
that's a Coulomb interaction it's a
force right it's the speed of light and
electric field so I see electron
themselve critically get surmised with
each other so effectively you can see
electron has a effective
temperature that's approximation right
and in fact a literature there are
debated whether electron how fast it is
to get a uniform temperature between
electrons let's suppose if you use that
electron temperature right so you have
an electron temperature and they are not
the same at the full on temperature and
that's where we have right electron for
long interaction and at the same time
the transfer right so if you go to start
from the Boltzmann equation
writing these two terms and you'll
manipulate the equation and this is a
similar when you read the chapter six
and when we I didn't go through you
could do the I said that you can derive
conservation equations right so you can
go through that process and what will
happen what you get is some equations
like you can write it the electron
temperature this is a model that you can
derive from both my equation with a lot
of assumptions okay again so and what
see here I have the standard diffusion
equation right this is the Fourier law
for electron diffusion and and then say
I have now the electron cop or the
photon te must TP and that's the
electron photon coupling so it's like a
say a convection right see electron for
long temperature difference times that G
is like effective heat transfer
coefficient between electrons and
photons and similarly you can write an
equation T P and D T P DT equals to
Delta and KP data TV and Plus G
description so why is losing energy the
other system is gaining energy the
photon is gaining energy so you have two
different temperatures and this is a
called
say to temperature model right so you
have electron is at its own equilibrium
local equilibrium and full knock is that
the different and in fact you're not of
this example pump improve experiment you
can clearly say a typical signal when
you do a pump probe basically you have
laser very fascinating and comes in and
the reflectance is a measure of the
electron temperature and in those kind
of signal you say okay your first type
pulse comes in and the temperature
change and in this region that's the hot
electron region and you can clearly see
that in the experiment okay so and for
this region in fact using this model is
reasonable you can solve the two
temperature model and describe the
electron phonon temperature but this is
the case cell full metal what if I have
a sim a conductor right so okay one more
comment for this in fact because I like
to think about boards my equation
no I have not found anybody so Alvin
Birds my question for electrons it's one
a second I have not found say this
equation neglected some electric
transport right if you look at it here
is the specific heat so internal energy
and this is a heat conduction and then
when we do charge we know there is a
thermal electric term right the Peltier
term that carries heat so in theory you
should be writing a modified equation
and say even for the diffusion term
there should be modified term this is
the diffusion both of the diffusion
right and then you say ballistic that's
a lot more complicated so you say you
and those kind of problems it's not
fully answer now if you go to look
either the next
I say you have to know what do you deal
with you if I give you a piece of metal
to do the experiment versus ideal give
you a piece of semiconductor to do the
experiment right so if I have a piece of
semiconductor what happens right and
here I have like concealed and
semiconductor is more complicated
because when my light is above the bank
gap right this is a this is a electron
the hole right so my you can say the
first step is I will heat up generate
electron-hole pairs an electron hole
pair quickly cool down so to the bottom
of the conduction and valence band and
then they will recombine that process
could be much smaller this cooling down
is a pick up second recombination in
different semiconductor in gallium
arsenide which direct gap is the
farthest could be Llano second so that's
already to a three order magnitude
different and if you deal with a very
good silicon with say because silicon is
a indirect gap right in the photons to
have that process happening so it's much
slower so the recombination in good
silicon could be as long as a second
okay very long process so what happens
now you say okay
I will have exponential decay absorption
coefficient right that's what the
profile of electron hole generation
that's what the absorption but if you
lay a we say okay if I don't know this
this absorption when I do a heat
transfer I would use that as in my he
sauce right say I say this is my heat
source distribution which is actually
not true if you think about what's the
physics involved
what is this absorption just say I'm
generating that a light power
Oh pear distribution and now the
electron hole pair has a say the excess
energy this part of energy right because
it happens very fast picosecond so I can
say okay immediately this part of energy
the profile is very similar so I can see
those part of energies generated at this
exponential decay and similarly on the
whole side you have this right but then
there is also the outer part across the
gap it's not released because there is a
it takes time for that recombination and
also I have to be careful that
recombination whether it's read it here
or it's long radio right it's really
it's long we did you generate the
photons if the reader would generate the
another photon that propagate again is
get a reabsorbed again in the material
right you see there okay so ah for so
for this part that's easy because
essentially you can use the time right
the what we can write is if I have
diffusion I am concerned because I
generate the gradient of electron hole
pairs and they were diffused into the
material and that they are you can write
the diffusion inclusion and I let me
just do a steady state again you can
make a depends on your experiment
depends on what to do it so I'm going to
write a diffusion equation diffusivity
of this electron all the concentration
gradient right let's suppose this is the
X okay and for this recombination term
here and there very often this can be
written as a relaxation time term in the
boards my equation and this is
recombination time
the rate of recombination okay and you
can say include the ball so really the
rule on radio you can distinguish them
if you want but I'm just going to just
to say I'm going to write this as M s
and 0 power equals 0 so what happens is
the career carriers generated will
diffuse and they recombine right it's
happening at the same time and if this
recombination is not read adhere you
will generate real awful heat source
that's different from the exponential
absorption profile right and so I see
this diffusion so the diffusion list
right how fast this is spread out then
you can see this is a standard diffusion
equation is the diffusivity times time
okay and the diffusivity if I take a
silicon as an example and this
diffusivity of silicon
diffusivity you say I only remember it
could be full for order magna higher
than thermal diffusivity that's what in
my mind and now thermal diffusivity ten
to the minus four right a centimeter
square
now meter square so wait so the thermal
diffusivity of silicon is of the 10 to
the minus 4 meter square per second so
diffusivity for electrons is of the 1
meter square per second okay for
magnitude higher and the relaxation is a
recombination time right if I do milli
second or second microsecond depends on
the purity very sensitive depends on the
purity of the materials right so I have
people doing solar cell I'll ask her
what's the recombination time of your
silicon okay 100 microsecond 10 to the
minus 4 second right if I do that I did
the square root of D times tau you can
go to see how large is diffusion of the
charge right so you have the point I
want to make is you have to know what
are you doing in this kind of fool each
process what's the detail charge carrier
transfer process to even find out the
where if example and you care at the end
heat transfer it was clear heat transfer
you have to say words or heat generated
okay so ah that's what I mean by coupled
charge a couple of the say conversion
and say energy conversion that's the
right-hand side and the left-hand side
is a transport and let's look at a one
specific example and we're not going to
say this example is the oil
you care about it let's look at solar
sail okay but to do solar sail our first
do conjunction you have to understand
that what is the PN Junction right and
I've mentioned it many times on
semiconductor in this course and not
very systematic and understand let's see
the basic picture we have so far is I of
course so here I'm drawing a band
structure right but see this at the end
of what matters is because it's really
near the bottom of conduction but on top
of the valence band right because the
carrier quickly relaxed to that region
so typically when we draw it away
actually just to draw a flag you can
store a point by the flag just so this
is my bottom conduction band and this is
the top of the valence band right and PN
Junction so when I have an n-type
material my chemical potential is here
right because if you think about our
Fermi Dirac distribution the e minus mu
right Emacs mill so this separation is
much more than this e mass mu so I have
more electrons what I draw is a lot of
electron in the conduction band
that's an n-type material and then I'm
drawing the same band gap because I'm
using the same band gap material you can
use a different band gap that's a hetero
Junction but here so I have this is the
n-type this is a p-type right they are
standalone now connect it
now you collect them you put them
together say the mule the chemical
potential is the driving force for mass
diffusion or charge flow right chemical
potential is a driving force for
diffusion we whenever you have a
temperature let's say imbalance in the
chemical potential there is a particle
flow so when I collect them together
eventually what will happen is this is a
steal my my my gap right
band gap and this is my mule so I'm
going to draw a new line here and that
on this side is going to be my p-type on
this side is my n-type so I line the
chemical potentials and then you
collecting the conduction band together
valence band together right and I say
approximately way to connect with the
parabola you can solve the Poisson
equation to find out the exact profile
and that's what the same typical
profile look like okay that's your pian
junction at the equilibrium right so and
here we have how I draw too large but
that's fine so what I have here is the
difference between the conduction bands
and the flat region far away from the
interface this is a say e V building
potential so that depends on you can see
you can actually do that exercise
quickly because the a way in this region
you still have your boards my
statistical Fermi Dirac statistics and
on this side so you once your line you
can find out what has to be the
- in band edge offset that depends on
the doping of the two material okay and
what what they're physically happening
so this n type I have a lot of for so
for the N type right I can draw this
when I collect the two material this is
the interface of the two material in the
N type for example is a phosphor right
in silicon is phosphor and it has five
five electron this free electron that
scale-free is moving to the other side
right so this is an N region the
electron is lost going to the other side
and what's left behind is the phosphor
atom right the phosphorus atom now
doesn't have a electron to balance that
anymore
so it's a it's a say actually positive
phosphor atom region these are not a
mobile right those are just atoms
sitting on the lattice okay and
similarly on the p-type side right its
boron doped and boron get that electron
and so boron becomes negatively charged
right so you have negative charge right
this is our this space charge region
there's no mobile charge it's atoms
positively charged the atom negative
charged atom away from the junction you
have a little region where there's equal
number of electrons and they say the
Isles but in this region is our neutral
right so this is the space charge region
okay and this so again the ways of this
depends on the dopant concentration and
if you have less dope in the space
charge region is the wider you have mode
open the space charge region is narrow
and tabular semiconductor with doping is
a few microns in this space charge
region okay
and uh so now that's the a steady state
right and they say a diet so your pin
Junction is a diode we know that let's
say it's a isotropic right and if I do
say a forward bias what do I mean
forward bias I apply a voltage right and
the voltage will change the
electrochemical potential so on this two
sides I have a difference now on
electrochemical potential now if I want
to have a forward bias should this going
up or going down
ah okay going up right so a forward bias
means okay now I have a camera potential
on the P side and electrochemical
potential okay at the inside and
here you'll become flattered
that's a pn-junction
under forward bias right you have to be
able to draw this is the N region this
is a P region and this is a new
collector so so if you think about your
collector a pin Junction Yahoo is a
battery right it's this side you connect
your negative side or positive side
negative side because when you do it
because the reason this protein sure is
a reason they like him becoming more
higher there so this is the day if you
collect this is positive right I forgot
right that's what you come back ok so
now I have our the the at least I the
electrode that's what it look like
right the question is how these two are
going to connect to each other
right so in the bulk of the PN Junction
away from this space charge region it's
pretty much electron itself with at
equilibrium so it's still very so it's a
diffusion very small deviation from
water we have in this picture here ok
but once you get to this space charge
region this equilibria is broken there's
not holes too low enough a host or
electron to still keep the electron hole
pretty much at equilibrium with each
other so electron and a hole actually
now-ish have equivalently a separate
time graphic picture this is a quasi
Fermi level or quota say electrochemical
potentials is so the way to draw this
and this is a where you have to say the
the invention opinion Junction right I
don't know whether told this story
before it was a was a Shockley it was a
budding was a Braden okay it was the
budding and so Shockley was i if I
recall correctly this chocolate was the
manager and budding I'm Braden did a
physical lab invention of the PN
Junction okay
and shocking no this is a very important
and he will be left out for the library
price he worked out the theory for this
okay so so Shockley got glory price for
twice right shock we got a lottery price
twice the order so this is semiconductor
and he got a library price for bcs
theory what is that that's a super
conductivity say is is Bardeen Shockley
and schrieffer cooper pcs where is the
bc o budding we were opening good yeah
but in order for a lower price twice so
okay not quite so chakra god words okay
but anyway so so there was an
interesting recount of the invention of
the diode in the bell lab so maybe I
mixed up the people but anyway I throw
my student got a good price a good good
practical result I got to get a lab and
I got my fingers there
okay we're where we are so here is what
happens you have to think about this is
a very very delicate picture electron is
the conductor in the n-type how that
transition going into a p-type go into
holes right holes are the conductor in
the p-type it's not a easy picture and
the theory that was sort out and you can
go to solve the in fact that's the
equation we have here is a carrier
diffusion equation and so what happens
is in the space charge region they say
this say I pretty much draw a flag
because the resistance in each region is
pretty small so resistance will
determine this quasi fermi-level if you
think about Ohm's know that's a voltage
drop if the resistance is small it's
pretty flat okay so why does he get over
so this is the junction there get over
to the T side and in fact get all of the
space charge region okay and then see
this is a steel electron here right you
like to on come over here and I say
really what happens is the minority
carrier which is a electron in this
region right because in this region the
majority electron the hole is minority
in this region is a hole is majority and
unites Homer molarity so once it comes
through this wreath other side it
becomes a minority and the maillard
carrier they were electron recombine
with the hole okay and that's a
recombination process and so the whole
supply is draw to this region by because
recombine with the molarity electron so
the electron you actually a pro
which equate a quasi equilibrium
electron the bulk region so this is this
recombination region so you have a long
equilibrium in the space charge and then
it's a recombination that drives the
quasi fermi-level approaching each other
on the both sides okay
and with that so this theory was worked
out so you can write they dial the
equation and I'm writing down the dial
the equation
I'm not deriving this giving in the book
so J equals the DAO equation J s
exponential Eve a KB T plus 1 okay and
the voltage here the this voltage
difference when between the
electrochemical potential on the two
sides
that's the apply the external applied
voltage okay and this J s is called
saturation current also dark current
right say it can be written as e for
this very long Junction say see this is
the conduction band the when you write
the charge distribution that's the
charge in the conduction band and here
and the valence band and this is the
acceptor and the dopant in the acceptor
is in the p-type region and the holes
the recombination time of hos
diffusivity a is d so that's a
diffusivity and this is the donor and
the diffusivity of the electron and
recombination time of the electron times
exponential the band gap
the eg KB T so this is the saturation
current or sometimes it is also called
our current depends on whether you deal
with solar sail or you deal with a dial
okay so if you look either the this here
it's a exponential function right when
we raise the voltage basically that's
because the carrier concentration is as
polar that's the Fermi Dirac
distribution or Boltzmann distribution
right the care constant depends
exponentially on the energy levels and
here the saturation current has a
exponential dependence of bandgap
diffusivity faster is larger
recombination time right is on the
denominator okay so if you that's a
error electrical engineer now stack
and in fact I say this is a you can say
the two terms so why is the electron the
other is a whole and of course in actual
device the current is continues right
and so if you draw this is a continuous
current this is a J that goes through
the device and this is the interface and
it turns out that the electron current
is roughly this is a J the space charge
region and this is recombination so in
this region this is the N region this is
the P region right in this region the
electron or supply because I say the
recombination for holes so this is a J
electron and you can also have a similar
complementary foot for holes
for whole this is the whole current so
this is zero here the tool add together
it's not not very well gravis so the to
add together should give you the total
constant J this is the hope
alright so in the electron n type region
electron is the majority here space
charge it's just a zip through and then
recombine with the minority carrier
recombine with the majority holes so
semiconductor the PN Junction this is
why people quote is a minority carrier
device it's very sensitive to
recombination so what it means because
the minority carrier is very sensitive
recombination you want the pure very
pure semiconductors okay and if you
recall previously I commented thermal
electrics thermal actually don't have
this majority carrier it's a majority
carrier base device so it's less
sensitive to recombination and that's
why I say we can use a some very low
tech like a ball mill a lot of de facto
steel works although the efficiency is
another wise high but see the pin
Junction solar cells you want the very
pure material let's sleep because
recombination so this is a again
standard wrong in books but the legs I'm
going to tell you something that the
most electrical engineer doesn't know
and this is a is a PN Junction a cooling
or heating huh
depends on what bias ah maybe yeah it
depends on bias yes but say for bias
okay of course you all know that the
semiconductor chips have a very severe
heating problem right so the answer
lecture should be heated but that's
actually not the case right so if you
look at when I have a forward bias and
the electron going so recall before I
said that the Seebeck coefficient is the
average energy of the charge relative to
chemical potential right so in this
region the electrons Seebeck smaller and
it comes to this region is larger so for
electron is actually pulling heat away
from the junction and same is the for
the holes and then where is he
generating the generation so in the
space charge region is actually cooling
and the generation is this recombination
when they recombine they reduce the heat
so if you draw a spatially and what
happens this is space charge and it's
actually something like this this is the
this is a Q generated let's say heat
generation so cooling in the center but
of course that's only a few micron right
and and there are more heat generate
dumpling immediate to that and this ki
the reverse back quickly so it's the
last cool as a healing but say what
happens physically is actually cooling
in the junction
okay and whether you can take advantage
of that and they are in fact some papers
trying to take advantage e you can
design how you design in turn a cool
device and say laser show diodes okay so
this is a pin Junction right now what
solar cell does so solar cell the basic
equation is based on this is just to add
a one additional term what happens is
now let's look at that solar cell
right and I have for example I make a
pin Junction by the way pin Jung's is
not absolutely necessary for solar cell
it's most of the diffusion charge
diffusion okay not some solar cell like
grasses see oh there's no pin Junction
inside okay so what happens is this is
my pin Junction right I put it under the
Sun and the light will come and get
absorbed so the way I make a pin
Junction is the for example this is a
say a p-type substrate and n-type doping
I put a diffusion put it in contact with
the phosphor and the phosphor diffuse or
an implant phosphor into the top layer
and then we compute in Junction right so
now the light strikes the surface and
the energy with a large larger than the
bandgap will lift the electron from here
to here of course we can go from here to
here right but for simplicity let me
focus on the space charge region so now
I have a space charge I go in from here
and lift say here that's the light
strike or higher energy for the bank the
energy of the photon is larger than
bandgap now I gotta access the electron
where they go they go here or they go
here huh
while they go to lower-energy first they
tend to go to lower energy right so
they'll go here first and when there are
a lot more access electron an access
hole the hole goes here right so
effectively you will raise the chemical
potential here you will say so now I
have a sort of a PN junction in forward
condition bias so what I have is a
really combination of two process right
I do have this situation I just draw but
say my charge comes from so I have all C
one is a generation the other is because
it is generated create a forward voltage
actually drive me the charge back right
so that forward voltage driving back is
this equation a generation I just a
source a ligature term so my PN Junction
equation for under illumination
becomes J equals J s exponential Eve a
KB T plus 1 minus J of the generation
this is the pair of electron holes and
say photons you first you think a
photons absorbed and the issue fold on
January 1 pair electron hole right and
say and that electron hole should
ideally I actually I want to extract
them out to this electrode but once I
have voltage generated will reverse back
some so I have the imbalance between the
two that's the lead current is what I
want to extract if when in fact if you
look at this forward your carnage should
be going this way right that's a lot
more dial if you want to make a
electricity you better get the legal
term all of this that means this the
ration is not balanced this reverse I
take out the from electrode right so
that's they say a equation here and if
you draw this car ristic right and this
is a diode of low C under say a lot more
diode okay and this will be the one that
you want other for you want the other
for say solar cell this is the current
this is the voltage exponentially
increase and it's in only in this region
negative current I'm extracting useful
work right so this is say you look at
the IV curve of a solar cell you are you
should look at this region how large it
is so this is the day at the zero
voltage I have G
and let's say either zero current I have
we all see that's an open circuit
voltage right short-circuit current and
of course the power is J comes way and
you have maximize it right so you have
to do your GW DV equals zero
there you get a way maximum G maximum
and that you look at this it's really
the small square inside so if my maximum
is here that's the that's the that's the
power I'm actually getting right you
ideally you say I want this voltage I
want this current but they actually
unless this is a square you don't get it
so people try to gather as close to this
square as possible and the holiday they
define that is they feel fair factor
okay
and F equals J M V M that's a maximum
and the J G vo C so that's the larger
square outside what do you dream to have
versus the assure you can extract right
and the most so you look at this curve
sometimes people make a sale they look
like this if you with your expertise you
can tell what you should do internal
resistance give actual resistance to
large so you have this IV into
resistance that resistant come from so
you have different mechanism that they
can have so different sort of will see
loss in this ear and the your game is
trying to extract as much power as
possible right then the question is
what's the maximum what's the best I can
do right first let's say JG I can say JG
is the number of electron hole pair I
can say this is a JG is let's say
electron and from the Sun to the earth
that's a view factor right and this
conversion of a photon we're talking
about the photon from the Sun dilute as
you go larger radius
it's what's a fraction of the say say
photon emitted fall into the earth and
then say the absorption so let's say I
do say 1 minus R Omega the reflection
that's assuming everything getting the
photon the front surface is absorbed of
course you could have transmission so
you really need to maximize that
absorption so this was this one you can
also write as a omega absorption right
and then if this is the solar spectrum
Sun which is the same temperature as a
function of Omega and that's the
intensity I divided by h-bar Omega
that's a number flux right because
that's the energy intensity
I just want to count the homily photon
is the excess energy I can capture the I
always have big a hot sale there and
this is the Omega so this gives me how
many the electron hole pairs are
generated in this field so that gives me
you can always max - suppose this is one
that's maximal number you can do absorb
all photons generally and of course you
have to count only the photons with
wavelengths larger than the bandgap
right if this is a band gap divided by
h-bar that's the corresponding frequency
to the gap band gap of semiconductor so
this term you can easily calculate and
the powerful research is actually on how
I can maximize this absorption will
minimize the material usage that's
related to your cost the key is how I
can if I want to answer this question
what's the maximum the question is the
what's here what's the minimum here it
turns out that you want this J s to be
small you go to do your math so what's
the minimum and this is the where again
Shockley okay and see he developed this
city Shockley and Queisser limit
they say even if here what we have is
really say diffusion recombination right
if you make a very perfect conductor
notes a diffusion is very large and the
recombination no defects inside now long
we did here recombination but you still
have to have the photon comes in you
have to have you can't just accumulate
there so they're taught to be the this
number balance there so you see the
radiative recombination actually gets
your maximum okay so once you have so
what chuckling say okay now you create
an open circuit right and let's suppose
I'm not connecting myself I have an
imbalance between another hole that's a
way there's no voltage drop there's no
internal resistance so eva is my balance
in the quasi fermi-level
so you're like Tron hole allowed at
equilibrium and the photon emission so
this is I said before normally we say
photon chemical potential is zero and
what chocolate written done is if you
have this dynamic equilibrium right
photon comes in radio recombination and
the photon immediate is the eve a si is
H Omega masse way over KBT say let's say
here I have a mass one there's a photon
right so normally if there's no Evie
that's the say Bose Einstein
distribution for photo
right but chocolate added this ee-vie so
photon now you meet it as a chemical
potential right you go to real chocolate
quite see this is a chocolate Kaiser
Shockley
I hope I'm writing everything right
Chalkley Kaiser ah okay this one you
have to check the name maybe I'm
spelling wrong this is chocolate Kaiser
limit and the chocolate Kaiser paper you
go to read it it's very difficult they
did a bad detail balance argument I
don't think I read fully through that
paper then I read many papers and this
is where really for many years I was
always the asking student in the classic
show me a better way to derive it okay
and there's another paper so by Henry
and this is a cited in the book you can
read that JEP there's another paper by
Ross I forgot where it was was in
chemistry journals so they did say then
there was a say I think they there's a
paper by war for Peter war for those are
some of the good papers sham to try to
read them they're really see how you can
derive this okay and so I spend actually
quite a long time and now I think I'm
roughly I can give explanation I'm still
trying to look at my notes to my
notebook and I didn't try to figure out
what I did so I'll give you this half
this story you can go back to make up
the rest okay so it turns out this one
you have to my view is you have to
this is also in war for paper you have
to look at the electron you have looked
at photon as a combined right because
it's the electron recombine with the
hole and generally folder so ah you can
write the first check they say
thermodynamic laws let's say the
electron energy right and the energy
equals DQ DQ is the TD se entropy right
and the my speedy way and plus mule e DN
e right so this is the day per second
law together for electrons I'm going to
also write the holes TDS whole mass P
eBay plus mule whole DN whole right so
in a recombination process I have my
electron number reduced by one whole
number reduced by one right and they say
so I sum up so P wait I don't know how
to deal with PV in semiconductor so I
drop it I'm still reading books so I
drop this okay the book to read is our
land ellipsis I was reading math like
like I said I always before in the sleep
okay now you do that you get a D E Class
D are I should do whole so T D s e+
[ __ ] and I said I drop that so so
this is malice because when I electron
and the whole recombine DN is negative
one right so I have so I have mass mu E
Plus mu H and this is the energy DV you
have to so here you have to look how the
electron energy increase in this way
whole energies increase in that way and
you have to write the details but just
to put in fact I was debating whether
it's a negative way or positive way so
my son has a problem maybe okay like I
said that's why I say I know I derived
this before but they're trying to look
at my notes
and here electron hole energy right this
system they decrease the energy by H
Omega because did we combine so I have a
same probably again you have to look at
this you have to so this is applying
your thermodynamics your second law your
first law you need to take your system
and you need to see the sign whether
it's the increasing or decreasing right
then the question is this right so here
is if you take this and you go to look
either electron photo interaction does
it generated if you meet a photon that's
a general entropy this is where okay I
say I can if I generate if I
me the full tongue I have no interview
generation if I do other stuff so what I
want
basically I'm arguing why this is you
read it's not reading anywhere okay I'm
just making this argument why this is
the most efficient really recombination
right and it's a process it doesn't
generate entropy so what I'm going to
have is this is the entropy decrease
because the electron hole loss so I say
I will say this is the equal a full
tongue entropy that's carried away right
if you make a car engine you don't want
entropy generation so this is the
entropy of the photon carried away and
the next step is you have to write
what's the entropy well because I need a
distribution what's the entropy a
distribution function relation right and
I wasn't assume a priori there the
Eukanuba
so I went to see because I know this
expression but actually I wasn't quite
sure whether it's valid for equilibrium
line qin emperor but then i say that
does put clearly say this is general so
this is the what that we have so for a
photon system or boson right the entropy
of a boson is 1 plus f log 1 plus f and
mass f log F so if you use this relation
if I say 1 so you take a derivative one
mode this is Samuel mode right so I'm
only taking derivative I have one mode
EF de and you solve this equation you
get a shockley-queisser
that expression okay so this is the one
that I finally feel comfortable to tell
because in the past I always ask the
student to show me because I read all
this paper I don't feel comfortable
maybe you can go to make up those detail
convince yourself it's a so I'm still
debating I'm trying to in fact this
morning this week I have program review
on the solar PV program project I have
with goe and the one of the question
I've been asking and I've been working
through this few months myself is it
trying to say what's the entropy
generation process in the solar sail
right because with that you will get the
maximum with the shockley-queisser
radiant recombination and in fact that
you don't even need this equation you
don't you need this equation you just
say chocolate Kaiser give me the voltage
that balance the the incoming the lead
difference it gives me the Karnataka
extract and you'll find the maximum
power and this is say if you do all the
maths
you find out that at the end this is a
typical curve of here the maximum
efficiency for one single Junction band
solar cell and this happened this is the
band gap of a semiconductor and this is
about a 1.4 and the maximum here depends
on which spectrum of the solar radiation
you use those numbers change chakra
quite so first I assume it's a blackbody
right and then say later on people take
the real solar spectrum and redid the
calculation so those lumber is around
30% efficient gets a cold shock
poisoning okay
any questions so I told you half-baked
work I was trying to find from my notes
okay you should be able to say the exam
problem